et on part tout de suite à la chasse aux
fausses infos
[Musique]
intox c'est avec Antoine fenaud bonjour
Antoine bonjour Raphaël Antoine fenou et
la tablette qui nous fait le plaisir
aujourd'hui d'être au rendez-vous
croisons les doigts mon cher Raphaël on
espérait que tout se passera bien mais
j'ai bon espoir
un truc aujourd'hui qui se penche sur le
Nigéria et une info que ça c'est subtile
vous allez le voir autour de d'une
destruction de cargaison de vaccins une
infox donc qui part de cette vidéo vous
apercevez derrière moi une diffusée sur
ce compte Twitter qui affirme que le
Nigéria détruit un plus d'un million de
vaccins légendes sont pas stupides
voyez-vous le pouvoir au peuple donc
effectivement qu'est-ce qu'on voit sur
cette vidéo on voit et bien un camion
qui décharge ce qui ressemblait des gros
cartons et à l'intérieur des photos
figées vous apercevez sur cette vidéo
donc de carton qui semble contenir ces
vaccins ce dernier donc il l'a partagé
avec avec cette légende et là pour y
voir plus clair et bien comme souvent
Raphaël les moteurs de recherche et
Internet sont votre meilleur ami on a
donc tapé nous à un fond intox Nigeria
un million de vaccins détruits qu'est-ce
qu'on tombe lorsqu'on ouvre une page
internet c'est bien on tombe sur une
pléthore d'articles qui font référence
donc à cette destruction de vaccin j'en
ai choisi un pour vous au hasard le
Progrès de Lyon qui nous donc qui nous
évoque ça cet article qui date où la
percevez du 23 décembre dernier
il dit il dit qu'effectivement qu'est-ce
qu'on apprend donc qui bien les
autorités nigérianes qui ont décidé de
détruire un million de vaccins car elles
étaient périmées des doses de vaccins
AstraZeneca en provenance de pays
occidentaux en particulier au programme
Kovax de l'OMS donnés au Nigéria mais
dont la durée de vie est très courte à
peine quelques semaines on vous le voyez
rien à voir avec les destructions de
vaccins par le peuple mais bien une
destruction par les autorités de 12
périmées donc cette vidéo en tout cas
soulève un problème à le faible taux de
vaccination au Nigéria et plus largement
sur l'ensemble du continent africain oui
absolument Raphaël un taux de
vaccination qui interroge nos confrères
de réutters ont recueilli les données de
couverture vaccinales au Niger comme
dans d'autres pays beaucoup de médias le
font ces dernières vous la percevez un
petit peu plus bas et à peine
4,8% donc un peu plus de 19 millions de
personnes vaccinés sont aux dernières
données que j'ai sélectionné pour nous
pourtant attention conclusion hâtives
sur ce sujet Raphaël pourquoi les
Nigériens et la population du continent
africain sont aussi faiblement vaccinés
il a bien sûr le fait de nombre de
vaccins disponibles ça on l'a dit mais
aussi une réticence qui s'explique et
c'est assez surprenant par certains
faits par exemple the conversation que
vous le voyez ici détailler un long
article avec en faisant intervenir des
chercheurs des médecins sur ce sujet
pourquoi l'Afrique est effectivement
moins touchée par le rock par le covid
et bien plusieurs raisons peuvent
l'expliquer ou le le contredire d'une
part l'expliquer la jeunesse de la
population qui dévore des formes un
symptomatiques mais aussi certains
facteurs génétiques ou encore ce qu'on
appelle la l'immunité croisée la
rencontre avec d'autres formes virales
donc il pourrait expliquer pourquoi il y
a moins de contamination attention
toutefois d'autres facteurs pourraient
également contreballer ça c'est ça et
conduire à une aggravation de la
pandémie sur le continent et on reste
sur le thème du covid avec une autre
infoque cette fois au Canada oui
absolument une
sur cette photo que vous apercevez ici
elle a été donc prise soi-disant dans un
Walmart vous savez cette chaîne de
magasins de supermarché qui est qu'il y
a beaucoup en Amérique du Nord avec
cette légende en anglais les on y voit
un homme donc qui attend devant un box
vitré vous la percevez l'internaute de
dire Walmart demande au nom vacciné
d'attendre dans ses box avant d'être
accompagné à la pharmacie Walmart
effectivement comme c'est le cas sur le
continent américain propose des rayons
pharmacie dans les supermarchés ce qui
n'est pas le cas en Europe il faut dire
que le le Canada une politique très
stricte très sévère vis-à-vis des noms
des non vaccinés ne peuvent pas accéder
au supermarché sauf à la pharmacie donc
ni acheter plus récemment de l'alcool et
du cannabis c'est internaute qu'est-ce
qui nous dit il nous dit que les non
vaccinés sont forcés donc d'attendre
dans ces box bleu que vous apercevez
pour se rendre à l'informatique la photo
a d'ailleurs été reprise et c'est
d'ailleurs assez surprenant par le site
du Parti conservateur du Québec lui-même
qui dit voilà à quoi ressemble les
cubicules donc c'est un le la traduction